as marijuana becomes legalized throughout
North America [Many] are trying edibles for the first time as a healthier option but with Edible marijuana
Providing such a different experience than smoking how does it work and is eating pot
Actually better for you? When you heat cannabis you effectively change the chemical makeup of compounds within it called Cannabinoids
Smoking heats it to around 800 degrees Celsius and converts thc a to Delta 9 thC
which binds to receptors in your brain making them continually fire and causing your
imagination, thoughts and perceptions to magnify this is why every thought can feel like a significant one and
Because it travels straight from your lungs into the bloodstream and to your brain the drug works within minutes and lasts about two to [three]
Hours, but when making edibles the weed is heated to around
150 degrees Celsius burning less of the actual plant and minimizing Carcinogens
ThC is Lipophilic not water-soluble
so the activated Thc
must be dissolved into something fatty like oil or butter and once the substance is consumed the onset of the high is delayed as the
drug is absorbed more slowly through your gut but this high typically lasts four to eight hours and most report feeling more high than
Compared to smoking marijuana
[this] is because when you eat edible weed the ThC is first metabolized by the liver before entering the bloodstream and here Delta 9 thC
also becomes 11 o h thC which
Passes the brain barrier more rapidly and is a more potent chemical so using the same amount of marijuana
You actually get more high with Edibles because it ends up creating both Delta 9 ThC
And 11-OH-THC which is a stronger compound and because there are more?
psychotropic types of
Cannabinoids acting on your neurons you'll be high for longer of course you also get to skip out on the toxic chemicals that smoking provides
like Carbon monoxide
Bronchial Irritants and tumor Initiators smoking anything means you're inhaling cancer-causing molecules
so if you can get high without smoking it will be healthier for your lungs and body the downside it's much harder to control the
High you'll get because it can take up to one to two hours to feel the full effects and the dosage can vary significantly
modulating the effects or
Titrating as it's called is much more difficult [and] as a result you can end up a lot higher than you intend
- but unlike those who consume too much alcohol
Opioids or other drugs you won't be suffering any serious long-term harm
Toxicity [or] Lethal overdose if you do consume more than you intended [if] you've ever wondered why marijuana gives you the munchies?
check out our AsAP stop video that breaks down the science behind that by clicking the screen or using the link in the description and
subscribe for more weekly science videos every Thursday